les premiers pas de liberté pour patrick
dils quitte en milieu de semaine après
quinze années derrière les barreaux
le témoignage de cet homme qui va enfin
selon ses propres termes faire
l'apprentissage de la vie à 31 ans fanny
auvergne et rémy poissonnier l'ont
rencontré cet après midi à paris c'est
la première fois qu'ils visitent paris
première journée d'homme libre
pour patrick dils qui retrouve les
choses les plus simples c'est magique
c'est rempli de couleurs ses rancunes
vif émoi de la vie ça fait quinze ans
que comme on l'a privé donc le bruit de
l'eau l'aller les oiseaux le vent les
odeurs patrick dils découvrent la
liberté le public lui doit faire sa
connaissance
ce n'est plus l'adolescent très timide
que l'on décrivait mais un adulte
parfaitement capable d'exprimer ses
émotions
quelque part j'ai même peur d'or parce
que c'est trop beau est ce que demain
matin quand je me réveille et il y aura
encore tout ça parce que je vais pas
avoir de nouveau des murs à l'épi
nouveau une porte fermée on
j'ai bien compris que j'avais été
acquitté et puis qu'on avait rendu mon
honneur et puis ma dignité ainsi que
celle de ma famille mais pour l'instant
ce sont que des mots il dîne en vouloir
à personne mais il exprime des doutes
sur la justice lui qui a été innocenté
après trois procès aux assises
si j'ai été victime d'une erreur
judiciaire je suis sûrement pas un cas
unique
je suis sûr que dans les prisons
françaises
il ya de nombreuses personnes qui sont
enfermés mais qui n'ont pas eu ma chance
d'être médiatisé qui n'ont pas eu ma
chance d'être entendue
patrick dils va travailler dans une
imprimerie mais il espère plus tard
pouvoir témoigner de son passé
judiciaire dans les facultés de droit